There is an absolutely stunning new report
from a longtime investigative journalist,
Carl Bernstein, about what is going on behind
the scenes with Donald Trump.
And multiple Trump administration officials
believe, No.
One, that Donald Trump is completely delusional
on the basis of a bunch of different phone
calls he's had with world leaders.
And number two, that Donald Trump's phone
calls with world leaders actually represent
a security threat.
And I'm going to go through some of the allegations.
I encourage you to read Carl Bernstein's primary
reporting directly because it is really, really
important.
So just a few highlights from from the report.
Multiple sources described Trump as bullying
and belittling allies while fawning over autocratic
leaders.
No surprise there.
Sources say Trump behaved in near sadistic
fashion with female leaders, that he talks
to Putin as if they're two guys in a steam
bath and that Turkish President Erdogan, quote,
took Trump to the cleaners.
Trump's behavior was said to be so unusual
and erratic that it convinced senior administration
officials that the president was, quote, delusional.
And this includes officials like, say, national
security adviser H.R. McMaster, former, of
course, almost everybody's former with Trump,
former national security adviser John Bolton,
former Defense Secretary Jim Mattis, former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson, former White
House Chief of Staff John Kelly, and intelligence
officials.
They believed that Trump was often delusional,
that he was disconnected from reality in terms
of what was going on in some cases, according
to Carl Bernstein's report.
Trump's actions led White House officials
to conclude that the president posed a national
security threat.
These are the people who are supposed to be
the top protectors of the American people
from national security threats.
Many of them believed that the president himself
was the national security threat.
Details about phone calls Trump would get
on the phone with other heads of state, including
Mohamed bin Solman from Saudi Arabia, including
Kim Jong un, the North Korean dictator.
And on the phone with them, Trump would brag
about his wealth, about his genius, about
his accomplishments, about how bad some former
presidents were.
The, quote, idiocy of former U.S. presidents,
according to multiple sources.
That sounds delusional to me.
That seems like it not just delusional, but
it seems also weaponized.
Narcissism is maybe a term I would apply now.
As usual, you know, every time you get one
of these reports, including from a very respected
investigative journalists like Carl Bernstein,
who understands the journalistic process,
Watergate reporter along with Bob Woodward,
you immediately just get Trump followers who
just say it's all lies, it's all fake news.
Bernstein did this report, wrote this up and
it was published by CNN.
You can't trust that it's all lies.
None of this goes against what we know about
Donald Trump.
You know, if we got a report that this was
something George W. Bush did, I didn't vote
for George W. Bush.
I think Bush was a terrible president.
But it doesn't sound like George W. Bush that
he would be bragging about his wealth and
business accomplishments, scene over the Texas
Rangers or whatever, oil money, whatever,
when getting on the phone with with with autocratic
leaders, it just wouldn't really match everything
else we knew about George W. Bush.
Bush was a terrible president, but that's
not something he would do everything about.
This report is exactly what we would expect
Donald Trump to do.
Based on what we already know about the guy,
not surprisingly, Trump would often attack
female allies of the United States who are
or were world leaders.
British Prime Minister Theresa May.
German Chancellor Angela Merkel were regular
targets of Trump during phone calls with other
leaders in addition to Merkel in May.
No.
One, Trump would also bully Merkel and may
when on the phone with them.
But sources also say Trump would regularly
bully and disparage other leaders of allies
like, for example, French President Emmanuel
McCrone, Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau,
Australian Prime Minister Scott Morrison.
The calls were, quote, so unusual to German
officials that German officials did everything
they could to cover up the content of these
phone calls.
This is what happens when you put a reality
show guy who's known for firing people on
camera in charge of the United States of America
is just not surprising.
There's nothing surprising about this.
It's extremely disturbing.
It highlights the urgency of.
Moving this malignant narcissist as soon as
possible.
But, you know, we saw what happened at the
Helsinki Summit.
We saw what happened with multiple North Korea
summits, every single scandal.
You know, it all clearly has been pointing
in this direction.
Who knew?
Right.
That the guy who asked a foreign country to
hack his political opponent back in 2016,
who could have predicted that he might not
be the best guy for national security.
So the trumpets are going to write this off.
Who cares?
We understand what's going on.
We can distinguish between a believable and
an unbelievable claim about Donald Trump.
All of this falls squarely under the bucket
of very, very much believable.
And that gets us to our next story, which
which I want to go into some detail on